we begin this morning with what could be
a washout of a holiday for millions of
people living along the Gulf Coast storm
watches are in effect from New Orleans
area to the Florida Panhandle southwest
of Tallahassee as subtropical storm
Alberto slowly moves north northeast
from the Caribbean Alberto is about 95
miles east of Cozumel Mexico packing
winds of 40 miles an hour the storm
brought heavy rain flash floods and
dangerous rip currents on Friday a
separate storm system brought heavy rain
to central Alabama on Friday at current
of our Chicago station wbbm-tv has the
latest on what to expect and good
morning well good morning and we're
looking at a system that will create a
lot of rain as it continues its Trek
here we already see rain streaming in
the southern Florida and we're looking
at the tropical storm watches that are
up here in the pink and the flood watch
throughout Florida also the concern up
here along the Gulf Coast a flash flood
watch in place we could see five to
eight inches of rain in this area and
it's not out of the question that
locally some areas could see maybe
double that amount Alberto is currently
40 mile per hour winds tracking to the
north-northeast at seven miles an hour
it will become better organized as it
travels through these warm waters we're
looking at a landfall probably around
one o'clock in the morning on Tuesday as
a tropical storm and you can see
Futurecast shows you the movement of the
storm as we go through this holiday
weekend Anthony what weekend in the Gulf
meteorologist said current of our
Chicago station wbbm-tv thanks ed